WAS GOING TO HAPPEN TO HIS
BUSINESS.
CHRISTINA, THANK YOU.
KRISTIN.
>> WELL, HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
INFECTIONS.
AND THE FEDERAL OFFICIALS ARE
STILL IN LIMBO.
JOINING US FOR MORE ON THAT IS
KENTUCKY CONGRESSMAN AND
RANKING HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE, JAMES COMER.
YOU SAW IN THAT REPORT FROM
CHRISTINA COLEMAN THAT
RESTAURANT OWNER CRYING BECAUSE
HE’S GOING TO LOSE HIS
BUSINESS.
BUT CONGRESS COULD HELP
BUSINESS OWNERS LIKE HIM IF
THEY PASSED ANOTHER STIMULUS
BILL.
DO YOU THINK ANOTHER IS
NECESSARY AND IF SO, HOW SOON
CAN THE AMERICANS AND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS HOW LONG WILL
IT TAKE FOR THEM TO GET A
LITTLE RELIEF.
>> I THINK THIS BILL IS NEEDED,
BUT IT NEED TO BE TARGETED.
THE LAST BILL, WE DIDN’T KNOW
HOW THE COVID PANDEMIC WOULD
BE, WE ASSUMED EVERY BUSINESS
WOULD BE HURT IN THE SAME LEVEL
AND THE PPP PROGRAM IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
EMERGENCY LOAN PROGRAMS IN
AMERICA.
MOVING TO THE SECOND BILL, WE
NEED TARGETED STIMULUS.
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY, I
THINK THE ONE INDUSTRY THERE’S
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT THAT THERE
IS A DESPERATE NEED FOR
ASSISTANCE.
BUT WE HAVE A SITUATION IN
WASHINGTON WHERE NANCY PELOSI,
SHE DOESN’T WANT TO DO TARGETED
STIMULUS, SHE WANTS TO DO
ANOTHER BLANKET STIMULUS BILL
AND GIVE MONEY FOR EVERYONE AND
FORGIVE STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND A
LIBERAL CHRISTMAS WISH LIST AND
WE CAN’T AFFORD IT.
KRISTIN: CONGRESSMAN, I THINK A
LOT OF AMERICANS ARE LOOKING AT
TIMING.
THE LOWER THIRD SAID THE LAST
STIMULUS WAS IN MARCH.
AND IS IT SAFE TO SAY THAT THE
NEXT BILL WOULD HAVE TO COME IN
THE NEXT CONGRESS, THAT IT’S
DEAD IN THE LAME DUCK SESSION?
>> I THINK THE CHANCES IN THE
LAME DUCK ARE STILL FUNDS,
THREE TRILLION IS A LOT OF
MONEY.
AND WE NEED TO HELP BUSINESSES
IN NEED.
YOU KNOW, FRUSTRATION FOR A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS,
THAT RESTAURANT OWNER WAS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR.
WE HAVE KENTUCKY WITH THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS WITH A DEMOCRAT
GOVERNOR.
MY DISTRICT IS ON THE TENNESSEE
STATE LINE AND YESTERDAY I SAW
ON FACEBOOK, A HUGE PERCENTAGE
OF MY RESIDENTS TRAVELED TO
TENNESSEE WHERE THEY DON’T HAVE
THE RESTRICTIONS TO EAT AND GO
CHRISTMAS SHOPPING.
THERE’S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE RUN THE
STATE AND THE REPUBLICANS RUN
THE STATE.
AND WE SHOULD NEVER HAVE WHERE
THE GOVERNMENT FORCES
RESTAURANTS TO SHUT DOWN AND
IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
UN-AMERICAN.
KRISTIN: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE EXTENDED FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
IN KENTUCKY THEY EXPIRE TODAY
AND ABOUT 4,000 PEOPLE IN YOUR
STATE ARE CURRENTLY RELYING ON
THOSE EXTENDED BENEFITS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS
HAPPENING BECAUSE IT’S
TRIGGERED BY THE STATE’S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FALLING BELOW
A CERTAIN THRESHOLD.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO?
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THE
4,000 PEOPLE IN KENTUCKY WHO
ARE GOING TO LOSE THEIR
BENEFITS, THOSE EXTENDED
BENEFITS TODAY?
>> WELL, KENTUCKY IS STILL
GOING TO HAVE UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK IS LOST IN TRANSLATION.
THEY’LL STILL BE DRAWING
UNEMPLOYMENT IT’S JUST ABOVE
AND BEYOND UNEMPLOYMENT.
A LOT OF OUR EMPLOYERS IN THE
DISTRICT HAVE BEEN VERY UPSET
WITH THE ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT
THAT FEEL LIKE THAT’S LED TO A
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
UNFORTUNATELY, HAVE MADE AS
MUCH OR IN SOME CASES MORE
MONEY DRAWING YOU CANS --
EXTENDED UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE A BUREAUCRACY THAT
PREVENTED PEOPLE DESERVED TO
DRAWING UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AND SOME ABUSED BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYERS TRIED TO CALL IT
BACK.
KENTUCKY HAS A LOT OF PROBLEMS
WITH UNEMPLOYMENT, BUT THE
REASON WE HAVE A HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE BECAUSE OUR
GOVERNOR SHUTS OUR STATE DOWN.
I WISH THAT KENTUCKY OPERATED
LIKE SOUTH DAKOTA ON FLORIDA,
AND THOSE ARE PRO--
>> AND THERE’S ALSO--
I UNDERSTAND, BUT THERE’S A
PANDEMIC GOING ON, AND STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE DEALING
WITH THESE UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH